foreign
a woman named Ruth called from Chicago
and she called to talk about her her
daughter had received a schizophrenia
diagnosis and she was calling to ask
about what she's what should she do what
happens next and she has a follow-up
call here Ruth are you there
yes sir okay every time I get a
follow-up call I always they don't tell
me
what the follow-up call is and so you
could be calling to be like oh by the
way you completely screwed this up my
whole like whatever or it can be really
positive so tell me
um tell me uh what's going on
okay well I I was meaning to write you
for a couple of months now and I just
finally decided that I needed to write
that letter and give you an update
um your advice because our specific
question was that she wanted to share
her struggles and her possible diagnosis
with her friends and and kind of live
more openly with this she was feeling
very alone
and um her dad my husband and I were
really fearful about kind of the
exposure that that would give her
um especially since the diagnosis wasn't
formalized yet and um so your advice was
to to kind of work around that and give
her some more trusted adults at school
to talk to and
um some some Escape Routes if things
were bad at school so we did that she
had we called it the golden ticket and
she could leave class if she needed to
um she never even used it but like
having that ability to escape was kind
of comforting absolutely um did a
counselor and we brought them in on it
if I remember did y'all go get some more
some additional medical testing
um she's been doing medical tests for
over a year basically when we talked and
we had you know all of it laid out in
front of us blood work and MRIs and eegs
and pet scans and the whole thing and
schizophrenia is is a diagnosis of
exclusion you know you just check
everything else and then maybe that's
what you're left with
um and that's what we were really close
to and um like teenagers do sometimes we
made a plan and then she just did
something else
uh she went and told some friends of
hers
um and I found out about it she kept it
from us and it was a huge fight
um not my most composed moment as a
parent
um
it was it was really rough and I felt
very scared for her and it came out as
anger and that was bad
um can I hold on one sec
um
can I give you some peace there
you just said that better than I've
heard it articulated by almost anyone
I've ever talked to
we're scared for your daughter and it
came out as anger
for sure have you told her since then
that you're sorry
yeah yeah we we picked our
I never I never
[__] up I can hear it on you
um
it makes perfect sense that a child
wanted to reach out to some of their
peers and say hey
um I'm unique but I'm also just like
y'all and so that doesn't surprise me in
the least and wanting you you to really
protect your daughter and we don't know
what this is like and it's unknown let's
just be safe stay close to the cave that
makes sense too right and so
yeah you probably said some things and
yelled and screamed and kicked and
whatever like I I again hopefully he
didn't kick anybody but
um yeah you got mad and then you said
I'm sorry and I think that's a that's a
beautiful wave in your relationship so
good for you I want you to set that
brick down though man okay thank you
um so there is also other good news
um we were the doctor we ended up with
had all this laid out in front of him he
was a neuropsychologist and he said
medically the only thing that we're left
with is schizophrenia he said but I'm
just not comfortable with it he says it
doesn't match enough she's not
experiencing any of the other things
that should be affecting her life and
her schoolwork and her relationships
um and he sent us to one more Guy and
um uh pediatric neurologist who ran a
test we'd already had but he ran it
again and he found something small
that doesn't usually have a lot of
symptoms with it he said try this
medication and we fiddled with
medication for a while and she is no
longer being bothered by her symptoms at
all and I'm really really grateful for
those doctors so is she having
hallucinations and
like what was she having
she was solely having visual
hallucinations okay
auditoring okay so no no voices just
seeing
okay so a distortion of her visual Fuel
and they didn't give up and I don't say
a schizophrenic diagnosis isn't medical
professionals giving up but your doctor
didn't take the easy route didn't just
do 15 minutes of okay it looks like this
here's some medication the rest of your
life they said I want to keep digging
because something doesn't add up good
for you good for your doctors that makes
me that gives me that restores my faith
in the whole system yeah that's so good
and I wanted to get to kick that back to
you because you had told me the same
thing you know just keep asking keep
fighting
um this may be where you end up but it
doesn't have to be and and you can keep
working for that so it was nice to have
a little incredible and what what a
blessing I know people um
really thumb their nose at medication
what an Incredible Gift and yes we are
people are way over Medicaid all the
blah blah blah but what an Incredible
Gift that we live in a sliver of History
where there is a medication for this
particular thing
right that gives you your daughter her
life back that's amazing so good yeah
well dude it was really important for me
to kind of just focus on the positive
for a couple more minutes and write that
letter to you it's it's been really bad
at our house on some other friends so
yeah I wanted to to be grateful for that
well thank you thank you so they said
you have another question
um I don't I don't know if it's really a
question I just um the reason it's been
so bad and the reason I was up late at
night writing this letter
um is that my husband was killed in a
car accident two months ago oh good God
Ruth
yeah so what happened
single vehicle no faults
my home from work
I'm so sorry
thank you
so um
yeah
I don't know that there's a question
that encapsulates that um you don't need
to ask a question every day just know
I'm sitting with you the next thing yeah
I mean that's I mean what else are you
gonna do right
nothing
what was his name
you don't say it it's okay will you tell
me something great about him
this whole income for the house and so
that's really scary to face going
forward but it's all of the other things
because everything is so much quieter he
was
so anyways laugh and he was the one who
told us it would be okay and we believed
him
and
he was the one who fixed everything when
it was broken so
it's just really different
I have five children 17 down to seven so
oh man
wow it's
it's really bizarre for me to try to
navigate
just myself but I'm also navigating for
five other people to you know try to
help them process that and it's
it's a lot but I don't know that there's
a lot of processing that you can help
with
I want you to relieve yourself of that
that's a heavy heavy burden
all right
um
your focus is being with
that makes sense
and I know it's easy for you as as a
parent of five kids to get caught up in
just the
I got to put that away because these
kids gotta eat and these kids got to get
to school and these kids I gotta keep
that air conditioner running and the
heater going or whatever
um
but if you haven't
honor him
honor yourself and honor your kids by
letting them see you hurt too
yeah yeah we're trying and that that has
certainly happened okay
um are you are you back
or is this still a fuzzy foggy dream and
you roll over and he's still there but
he's not no it's it's horribly real okay
who's walking with you during this
season
um we have some good
good support for extended family and
from our church family and a lot of
people looking out for us in a lot of
ways and we're just
everybody takes a piece of the puzzle
and hopefully it it comes together
somehow
that's a very evasive answer
let me ask you this way and I want to
protect you I know I know I know
do you have two or three or four women
that you can text and call 24 hours a
day three 165 days a year and say I need
you to come get his shoes out of the
house
I need you to come over to my house
right now because I just need someone to
hold my hand and lay here by me
you have that okay good do you promise
that you'll you'll lean on them yes okay
I'm gonna tell you something hard to
hear
okay
um this will get heavier before it gets
lighter
okay
and there's this sense that we're over
the hump this is the way this is and
then we're just gonna plow through what
comes next and this it comes in waves
okay
and
there's not any contrary to popular
belief there's not a lot you can do to
fortify yourself for the big wave right
what you can do is surround yourself
with people
who will hold your arms up and hold you
above water when they hit
and they will hit
okay
and I'm not telling you that to
be to be a jerk I'm telling that because
I love you I know no it just is
um
so yeah it I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry
thank you and for what it's worth one of
those nights where I stood there and
just stared at the ceiling and said I
can't do this I just decided to write
about something good that turned out
right so that's where it got us here
that's awesome well thank you for
honoring me
um
I'm telling your story and thank you for
honoring your husband sounds like he's
an amazing guy
um
honoring his story say say a couple of
those things so I'm thinking about just
a dad driving home from work today
um
who's kind of like
is suddenly going to be snapped back
into reality that they've actually had
the privilege to drive home today
what are what are some things your
husband brought to you sound like he
brought light and he brought joy and he
brought laughter what are some give me
two or three things that he brought to
your home
that you you want to communicate to
other knuckleheaded guys out there
driving home with their dead-eyed
loosened Tire on their neck
hmm
[Music]
thank God because otherwise I would be
in a mess I would be in a mess
almost out of the back of her head
sometimes can I tell you this too
if no one's told you this there's going
to come a moment if it hasn't happened
already
When You're gonna laugh really really
hard
about something
and then you're gonna feel guilty about
it
you're going to have a good morning when
you get the kids all off to school and
nobody breaks down and
even some of the younger ones help with
the other kids lunches and it just kind
of happens
and all of a sudden you're gonna realize
that
this is life moving forward
and then you can feel guilty you're
going to feel sick about moving forward
and I want you to know that that's a
normal part of the process and you're
not screwed up and you're not broken
and it's okay to feel Joy again and it's
okay to laugh again and it's okay to be
laughing and then all of a sudden start
crying all the same time and it's it's
okay to have a bunch of people over and
then five minutes in you're like
everybody out everybody out not today oh
that's okay
so good
so good and then hey once a month ride
them again
yes golly
yes yes yes yes do you have a you have a
group have you sat down with a group of
do you meet with anybody who has lost
people
lost somebody
you're amazing Ruth
if I can help you in any way along the
journey let me know okay I'm gonna send
you stay on the line and I'm gonna send
you every single deck of questions for
humans I got
about families and kids and all that so
that way when it gets quiet in the house
some there's always gonna be a deck
laying around that you can pull up and
be like all right and you can pull
something up okay
that's I don't know if it's gonna help
at all that's uh I'm just trying to
think of something I can I can leave you
with add a little bit of joy into into
your home but there's gonna be it's
gonna be a shadow
I mean yeah that's kind of that's creepy
on top of weird
you should put a sign on your front door
that's like I like your food please
don't break in I'll kill you that'd
probably be good
that that's
that simple uh
uh gosh sometimes men try to help and
what are you doing what are you doing
wow
it is but it's super not don't break
into so
golly
ah man hey we love you Ruth and anything
we can do um please don't hesitate to
let us know
I'm sorry
I'm heartbroken with you
and
that's all I'm gonna say